أمس أمضى اليوم كله
ميونيخ بعد أن غادر إلى النمسا
دائما للدفع
فحوصات تتعلق بصحة
يا فتى أعتقد أن الأخبار السارة
اليوم هو أنه لا يوجد
من العملية التي هي بالفعل جدا جدا
بشرى جيدة بعد كما أخبرتك
نقول أننا منحنا أنفسنا الفرصة
لنلتقي في الواقع خلال الأسبوع
التالي وسيتزامن مع ذلك
إصابة ساديو ستمتد لأسبوع
ربما 10 أيام ومن هناك نحن
سوف تفعل آخر تحقق RM لنرى
تطور هذه الإصابة هناك أنا
فضل إبقائه في المجموعة بسبب
أن هذه هي المواقف التي لدينا بالفعل
معروف بـ Rémois بـ
إسماعيل النجم في CAN التي عرفناها
تعامل جيدًا مع ساديو يفصل بينكما يومًا
في قوتنا العاملة لدينا
من المهم أن تستمر
الاصابة املا في اي حال من هنا
قبل أسبوعين أو ثلاثة أسابيع
سيكون لها تطور ولكن نحن
متفائل حقا